Let's do an example to figure out how to do generalization.
What do we generalize over?
Well, we generalize over problems.
So we're going to need another problem.
Rather than have a problem dealing with costs,
which we saw were complicated ,
let's just do a problem where we're finding the shortest path.
That is, the least number of steps to a solution.
I'm going to choose a classic problem called the "missionaries and cannibals" problem.
It works like this: there's a river we have to cross, similar to the bridge but this time it's a river.
We've got a boat, and on this side of the river, there are 6 people.
No flashlight, but a boat and 6 people.
Three of these people are missionaries,
and three are cannibals.
The goal is to get everybody over to the other side.
What makes it hard is that there are two rules.
One, at most 2 in the boat.
One person can go in the boat and cross from one side to the other,
but it takes either 1 or 2 people to get the boat from one side and to get it back.
The other rule is that we don't want the cannibals eating the missionaries.
If we leave more cannibals that missionaries on either side of the river--
either on this side or over on this side--
then the cannibals are going to gang up and eat the missionaries,
and we won't be able to accomplish getting everybody across.
We have to shuttle them back in forth in such a way that this never occurs.
Now, let's try to come up with a good representation for state.
One possibility would be to have a set of missionaries,
a set of cannibals, and a boat--let's call that a Boolean, yes or no,
saying what's on the starting side
and leaving out what's on the other side, because we can figure that out.
Given that we know we three missionaries,
If there's a set of 2 on one side then the other side there must be 1.
Another possibility is that we have 3 integers:
the number of missionaries, the number of cannibals, and the number of boats
that are on the starting side. These are all integers.
Then the third possibility is that we have 6 numbers:
the number of missionaries, cannibals, and boats on the first side,
and the number of each of those on the other side.
It may be subjective which of these is best, but I want you to tell me
which of these would sufficient for representing the state.